residents in a place called hassan abbad
in the mountains of north pakistan are
still picking up the pieces after much
of their village was destroyed in a
flood back in may the disaster happened
when a glacial lake burst its banks the
government in pakistan says 33 such
lakes are at risk of overflowing with
potentially devastating consequences
three of the world's most spectacular
mountain ranges intersect in pakistan's
north the hindu kush the karakoram and
the himalayas forming the largest
reservoir of ice outside the poles the
country's mountainous north is home to
more than 7 thousand glaciers
in a moment we'll have more from a
climatologist on why glaciers are
melting at such a rapid rate and what if
anything can be done to prevent the next
catastrophe
people in the mountain village of
hassanabad still cannot believe what
happened to them
in may dozens of homes were swept away
or damaged in a flood
caused by the melting of a nearby
glacier
the water came barreling down in the
middle of the night
women and children were screaming
some people were rescuing children
women were trying to save household
items
it was like doomsday
many of the residents are now living in
tents
one of them ngo researcher sahida share
says they have no money to go anywhere
else
what shocked her and others she says is
that buildings considered safe were also
destroyed such was the power of the
water
we lost everything within two hours
we lost our land and homes but there are
still some that are suffering internally
unable to express it
and the danger is far from banished
glaciers in pakistan are melting because
of heat waves caused by climate change
the water is creating thousands of
glacial lakes
more of these have burst their banks
this year than ever before
and the government is warning that more
communities are at risk
in many places the damage is already
done as one business woman in an area
close to hassanabad explains
there was a beautiful lake here and this
place was like an island
an international and national level ice
skating event used to take place
but within a year
everything is gone
you can't tell what was here before
looking at what we have now
people in hasanabad are trying to
rebuild
but some fear it's only a matter of time
until the next disaster hits
and while pakistan is responsible for
less than one percent of global
greenhouse gas emissions
the lives of its people are already
being destroyed
and arun shrestha is a senior climate
specialist with the international center
for integrated mountain development and
he joins me from kathmandu in nepal
welcome to the program
thank you okay can you give us a
snapshot of the himalayan glaciers how
bad a state are they in
well uh
the
glaciers in hinduku shimale region
that's what we call this region is uh
you know in general uh shrinking quite
rapidly just to give you an idea in
terms of number
between
1980 and 2010
and that's a period of
the study we have so far most updated
in nepal for example
the glacier area reduced by about a
quarter 24 to be precise
in what one 23 percent
right in in part of indus basin it
reduced by 21 so
within those years around uh you know a
quarter of glacier area has reduced
that's the past record
so
that alone
uh can tell that the situation is quite
quite serious quite dramatic
and
you know and it's not just about glacier
area shrinking
it is also about what that means for
different sectors so it's quite quite
serious i would
say can you talk about early warning
systems i wonder if it's possible to
predict what's called these glacial lake
outburst floods
so you know there are many ways to
manage uh
that kind of
floods
and one very effective way is early
warning system that means you place
certain device
uh you know close or on the lake so that
it tells
that a glacially outburst blood glove
event has happened
and then you know release that
information downstream and that
information can be transmitted to you
know
communities who would
which would be impacted by that flood uh
through different uh you know media it
could be through mobile uh messages
or you know sound uh you know systems so
that's called early warning system which
is very critical but unfortunately
early warning system
in in this part of the world is quite
limited
uh both both at national level but also
i would like to mention that in many
cases those glove risks are
transboundary that means a lake might be
situation situated in one country but if
a glove event happens
that could impact not only that country
immediately but also countries
downstream so that is the transboundary
dimension
and then when we talk about
transboundary early warning system
there are almost none in this region so
uh the vulnerability and the risk of
gloss
glove is quite high
and you know rewarding having early
warning system is quite quite important
that actually
really makes me think that the situation
in the in the mountains of pakistan
seemed
determined by emissions produced by
countries far away right uh if you talk
about transnational
you know countries like china and the
united states um producing so much
emissions and impacting this corner of
the world is there anything that can be
done locally
to prevent the glaciers from melting
more
uh i agree with you you know um many of
those countries emit quite uh quite less
so their contribution to global warming
climate change is quite quite low
uh but they are actually being impacted
quite uh
significantly
but having said that i quickly add that
even countries in the neighborhood like
india and china are rapidly increasing
their emissions so they are not that low
right
but small countries like nepal bhutan
and even pakistan their share is very
low but impact is quite high
so when it comes to you know managing
the risk there are multi-tiered tired
approach that we could think of
but the first thing we need to think of
is who are going to be impacted most
and the answer is clearly it is the
communities who are living in in the in
the local localities
uh and there could be many different
impacts you know scarcity of water
extremes failure of agriculture and many
others so
definitely in terms of impact
there are many ways that local
communities can be capacitated
with
different measures to
adjust and adapt to
those kind of impacts
local level early warning system is one
climate services for example
providing information to farmers about
what is likely to happen
uh in the short-term and longer term
climate systems and weather
and many other options i think there are
available but then also i think
we need to think of
you know measures that can be
implemented at national level going a
little bit higher than uh local level
but also at transnational level but all
those needs you know resources it needs
capacity it needs you know
support external support otherwise this
region itself independently probably
will find very difficult to
manage those risks
arun shrestha thank you so much for
joining us
my pleasure thank you
you